the vague ramaswamy is in hot water
here's the headline the headline is the
vague ramaswamy is a 911 truther
Vivek ramaswamy says 911 was an inside
job and the government totally did it
and I saw that headline I said well you
know
I've known Vivek for some time now that
that doesn't seem
like his view I mean that's a little
suspect to me let me look a little
deeper then I realized it's it's
basically a fake hit job from the media
he went on CNN to discuss it here's the
line of questioning a report in the
Atlantic that you gave an interview to
you said quote I think it is legitimate
to say how many police how many federal
agents were on the planes that hit the
Twin Towers maybe the answer is zero it
probably is zero for all I know right I
have no reason to think it was anything
other than zero but if we're doing a
comprehensive assessment of what
happened on 9 11 we have a 911
Commission absolutely there should be an
answer the public knows the answer to
explain to me what you meant there
this is really it's funny I mean the
Atlantic is playing the same game as CNN
it's funny what I said is on January 6th
I do believe that there were many
federal agents in the field and we
deserve to know who they are on 9 11
what I've said is that the government
lied and this is incontrovertible
evidence Caitlyn the government lied
about Saudi Arabia's involvement there
was a Saudi spy named al-bayumi who they
lied and the government lied in the 911
Commission lied we know that because
Declassified reports in 2021
was indeed what's that yeah the report
that the President Biden Declassified
but your quote here are you telling me
that the quote 20 years later yeah but
are you telling me that you're doing
this wrong here because it says
do I live in North Korea I I guess this
is part of my political naivete because
when I was a kid I was taught that the
media the journalists they exist to
speak truth to power all those other
terrible regimes around the world Russia
China North Korea they all just have
state propaganda for their media but not
us in America
and then I I watch this and what does
this woman say Caitlin Collins she says
how dare you question the government
about anything are you you're a crazy
conspiracy theorist he says no wait hold
on I'm not a crazy conspiracy theorist I
didn't say anything crazy I'm just
pointing out we know for a fact now even
Joe Biden would admit this we know that
the government did lie about at least
the involvement of Saudi Arabia in in
the in the intelligence apparatus in
Saudi Arabia so they suppressed that so
we're just asking some questions about
about
the government isn't that what we're
supposed to do aren't we supposed to be
skeptical of power I'm not saying that
it was you know some like space aliens
or or I'm not saying it was you know
George Bush was hijacking an airplane
I'm not saying anything like that I'm
just saying the government lied about
Saudi Arabia's involvement so we should
continue to press them on on unimportant
National matters okay we now know that
because they lied and what does this
woman do
she interrupts him she says we know they
lied because great glorious leader Joe
Biden Declassified to the documents he
our great wonderful glorious leader of
the son Joe Biden good good wonderful
man he did it and so now that is the
truth before he did that whatever the
government previously said was the truth
but now that the Sun King Kim eel Biden
has declared that Saudi Arabia was
somewhat involved now we can say that
now all hail the Glorious leader
and empathy says wait what yeah that's
my point you're making my point lady
could have been he could have been
speaking Korean on there wouldn't have
looked any different now
when you want answers to your problems
you you shouldn't deal with our liberal
establishment when you want a quick
answer to a problem like hey you just
ran out of propane you got to check out
cinch right now go to cinch.com use code
Knowles picture the perfect Summer Night
the warm breeze on your face as you
Lounge in your favorite chair outside
the grill is sizzling with Juicy Burgers
and the aroma of the food is
irresistible
you're salivating the drool is dripping
down your chin now imagine what this
perfect summer night would look like if
you went to turn on the grill and your
propane tank we're empty
that's where our friends at cinch come
in cinch is a propane grill tank Home
Delivery Service they deliver propane
grill tanks right to your door cinch
delivers on your schedule requires no
long-term commitment or subscription
plus delivery is completely contactless
you don't have to wait around at home
track the order on the Cinch app from
anywhere whether you're grilling steaks
or lighting up the patio heaters on a
cold night cinches propane delivery
service ensures that you have the fuel
you need to make the most of every
moment go online to cinch.com or
download the Cinch app to order new
customers can get their first tank
exchange for just 10 bucks with promo
code nolts Canada wles that's cinch.com
or download the Cinch app and use promo
code nulls kwles to get your first tank
exchange for just 10 bucks this is a
limited time offer you must live within
a cinched service area to redeem it
visit cinch.com offer for details
President Biden landed in Maui
one of the first things he says he lands
there and he makes he makes a joke
about the Heat
you guys catch the boots out here
it's hot ground man
an estimated 480 people have been killed
at the very lowest estimate and 850 are
missing and the death toll is almost
certainly well above a thousand uh
pretty hot ground huh
isn't that funny
better wear some boots
then he goes on he's giving a speech
wearing a Hawaiian leis giving us a
speech
[Music]
and he
he has the temerity to compare the fire
we were talking about September 11th
earlier in the show if a thousand people
died in Maui who knows how many it could
have been more by the way if a thousand
people died that's that's a third of 9
11.
that is a third of what is considered to
be the greatest tragedy in American
history
and what does Joe Biden do he Compares
it to a kitchen fire in his house
I don't want to
compare difficulties but we have a
little sense Jill and I
what it's like to lose a home
years ago now 15 years ago I was in
Washington doing Meet the Press
it was a sunny Sunday
and lightning struck at home
on a little Lake it's outside of our
home not on a lake a big pond
and hit a wire and came up underneath
our home
into the heating ducts the air
conditioning duct make a long story
short
I almost lost my wife
my 67 Corvette
and my cat
put all kidding aside
I watched the firefighters
the way they responded
no there's an old expression
I grew up right across the street from a
fire hall in Claymont Delaware
you couldn't script this If you hired
the best writers in Hollywood you
couldn't script
he walks up there and he says ha ha yeah
I don't want to compare tragedies or
whatever but uh you know one time I had
this small kitchen fire that was very
quickly contained but and I know you
guys lost like hundreds and hundreds of
children like whole families burned up
and yeah but I almost lost my Corvette
anyway
what
is wrong with this man
I'll tell you exactly what's wrong with
it I know exactly what's wrong with him
this I want to be as charitable as I can
you know I don't just throw bombs
this is an occupational hazard of
politics and Joe Biden is all politics
he is not a living breathing human being
with flesh he is just the a visible form
of politics he doesn't have any thoughts
he doesn't have any beliefs he doesn't
have any principles he just does
whatever he thinks the crowd will need
to get him elected he's been in politics
for
the majority of his life he's been in at
the national level for over 50 years
and Joe Biden charitably we would call
this empathy
okay this is the the ability of
politicians to
feel compassion with their constituents
or at least to perform compassion this
is why when Hillary Clinton went out
years ago and started putting on this
fake southern accent I don't feel no way
he's tired I I made fun of her but I I
felt for her because I don't think she
did that consciously I think she just
that's what politicians do they just
naturally feel some resonance with the
people that they're with and they they
try to find some common ground so you
could charitably call that empathy
you could uncharitably call it vanity
just making everything about themselves
but here's a good rule for solemn public
speeches when you're talking about
what appears to be turning out to be the
one of the greatest tragedies in
American history
delete the first person pronoun the
first person's singular pronoun just
delete it I don't care you're giving a
wedding toast you're giving a eulogy
you're giving a political speech after a
tragedy delete it
delete it's not about you man the in
polybius's
good old ancient uncle polybius
in his take on the cycle of regimes the
different kinds of regimes that can
Decay into their their bad version you
know you have monarchy monarchy can be
perfectly fine they're wonderful
monarchies in the history of the world
but then the bad version is tyranny
you know you've got uh aristocracy
that's the good version literally means
rule by the good and then you've got the
bad version that's oligarchy where
you've got democracy which
people have had conflicting views on
over the history but the bad version of
democracy according to our founding
fathers would be mob rule well what's
the difference what separates those
things uh Thomas Hobbes the author of
Leviathan one of the people who
inaugurated modern political science uh
one of the probably the grandfather we
would say of liberalism the classical
kind and the modern kind and all of it
he would say that there's really no
difference between those things it's
just we say one regime is good and the
other one is kind of bad ours when we do
it it's good when other people do it
it's bad but there's really no
substantive difference but what polybius
would say is what the ancient Greeks
would say is that the good version is
when the Monarch or the aristocracy of
the Democracy are legislating for the
common good and the bad version is when
the Tyrant or the oligarchy or the mob
are are ruling for self-interest
and when a when a ruler just talks about
I mean my I mean my all the freaking
time you know what kind of regime you're
living under boy what a great clip that
was huh now
make sure that you ring that Bell
subscribe to the Michael Knowles YouTube
channel we'll see you next time